I'm a follower and a fan and have done
my best in my coaching to Institute some
of many of the concepts especially
infinite game especially just cause
the way I want to approach this on
behalf of this audience and even myself
is with genuine curiosity about the gaps
that I'm still struggling with of how to
take these Concepts and bring them into
a reality
and I think one of the first things that
could cause some folks to bristle is if
I were to ask the people out here how
many of you consider yourselves
extremely competitive and and winners
how many of you would would get on board
with that I think this is an identity
that so many of these higher Achievers
have adopted so the moment that you're
talking about not being in that you know
winning being first these these Concepts
as what's driving and it's the wrong
conversation how do you reconcile that
for
our leaders who have had so much success
already well let's be clear I'm
competitive I Am A type personality my
personality probably very similar to the
the people in this room well not in this
room but in this space
um uh
um it's not necessarily about uh being
competitive or not being competitive
it's about knowing the game that you're
in when you're in it so for example if
you're up for a job and somebody else is
up for a job that is finite there's a
beginning middle and end and there will
be a winner and there will be a loser
and you should have a finite mindset in
in that scenario of course you play to
win however everybody knows that you
have to have a little bit of an infinite
mindset in the back of your mind
um for example a a gate agent in an
airline we want them to have a finite
mindset we want that plane to leave on
time beginning middle and end done reset
but we want them to have an infinite
mindset we want them to treat us nicely
because they want us to come back again
it's not just one and done we want to we
want to we want to treat our clients
with respect it's not just about doing a
good job and getting out of there there
is actually good customer service so
that we get hired again or recommended
in other words we have a sense that
there's more Beyond right now but it's
more about when you think about the
business of a writ large right the there
is competition in an infinite game the
the truest competitive infant game is
yourself
right to say I'm the best EX you know in
in the industry is nonsense because you
don't know everybody else and some
people are better at some things and
some people are better at others it's
actually a stupid comparison it's a
stupid thing to say it's it's it's
empirically not true
um but you can strive to be a better
version of yourself
how do I do better this year than I did
last year how do I improve my service
this year make it better than it was
last year how to make my leadership
better this year than it was last year
how do I improve my tech this year than
it was last year whatever the thing is
there's always a constant and intense
drive to win and or to improve rather
but when we say to be to win uh there is
no such thing as a Finish Line even
annual goals are arbitrary like how do
we come up with our annual goals here's
how we do it we sit down we go so uh how
much business you want to do next year
how about this number
how about this number okay and that's it
that's how you picked your annual goal
and the reason we choose annual is
because that's when we pay taxes why not
why not 17 months that seems perfectly
legitimate it's all arbitrary and so we
become fixated about hitting an
arbitrary number on an arbitrary date we
are so upset if we miss it and we think
we've won something when we hit it it's
nonsense we have to change our mindset
away from thinking like a sporting event
and think of it more like lifestyle
right running a business is much more
like trying to be healthy right so for
example what are all the things you have
to do to be healthy well you got to eat
right you got to exercise you got to
nurse your personal relationships you've
got to get enough sleep there's probably
15 other things it's very hard to do all
those things well all the time what does
it take to build a great business you
need great sales you need great
marketing you need great leadership you
need great people you actually got to do
the service it's very hard to do all
those things well all the time but it's
a striving it's a striving right and you
can absolutely have arbitrary goals
right I want to lose x amount of weight
by X date okay great and you weigh
yourself every day some days you feel
good about yourself some days you feel
bad about yourself we love metrics
there's nothing wrong with metrics you
can't run a marathon without mile
markers it's actually unnerving metrics
help us feel like we're making progress
it makes feel like the work is actually
uh building something
and it helps measure it helps us measure
speed and distance that's what metrics
do speed and how far has our business
gotten how fast are we growing that's
good right and let's say you hit your
goal you you lose that amount of weight
on the right date
you feel great you celebrate
and then you still have to keep
exercising for the rest of your life
like you haven't won anything yeah right
but what's I think more interesting is
what happens if you don't lose the
weight by that by that date what happens
if you miss the goal yeah you know what
happens
nothing
happens in fact you're way healthier now
than you were when you started because
you've been doing all the right things
to be healthy you just picked the wrong
time and the wrong date uh the wrong uh
the wrong number on the wrong date and
you can clearly look at the trend that
you'll hit it in a month or two no big
deal right and so business is the same
way which is what's more important in an
infinite game is to see the trend data
so we we do this all the time we bonus
people because they hit a goal and we
ignore people because we ignore the
trend right but we don't know how they
hit the goal or if it's going to be able
to continue what's way more important is
the trend data because it means you're
building a healthy business you just
pick the wrong date on the wrong time so
that's an infinite mindset this is
fabulous and the piece that you just hit
on actually this is really interesting
because the the person who first sent me
the infinite Game the book uh to read it
and and made me aware of it was a
business owner wanted a service Titan
client radiant Plumbing Brad case beer
and I've watched yeah we've got radiant
a couple radio members right here front
and center beautiful and Brad case beer
was the first CEO that I've seen who
made it really clear they do they have
an incredible annual budget building
process and then I watched him
adjust the budget because we hadn't made
enough hires to hit the number that we
wanted to hit that's correct and he and
and and you just said that's I want you
to hear that he just said that's correct
so there we have a long-standing belief
especially in this industry that I've
witnessed that you set the budget and
the budget's budget and you go get the
budget by any means necessary
I mean if you didn't learn a lesson from
covid
you know my favorite thing when covet
hit I used to get this question all the
time Simon during these uncertain times
and I would always interrupt them and
say
um all times are uncertain there's never
been a time that was certain
all that happened was something that you
didn't expect actually happened that
reminded you that time was uncertain
um and so you know to be so dogmatic
about a budget when we don't control
anything you know the Marine Corps knows
this they the Marine Corps has a has a
has a maxim you know no plan ever
survives contact with the Enemy well I
don't think any budget or any plan
survives contact with reality you know
um and the rea and the fact of the
matter is it changes now that doesn't
mean we should change it Loosely but we
should be realistic I'll give you a a
another way of thinking about it think
of a retail operation right uh they have
a goal we're going to open 200 stores
this year but to your point they're
hiring so quickly and they're opening
stores so uh uh um uh to hit that goal
that they're hiring the wrong people
they're not training them and they end
up opening bad stores so they'll hit
their goal but then what happens the
next year and think about the problems
that they're making for themselves
it's better to say we're going too
quickly growth is a dial it's not an
absolute let's open 20 stores properly
yeah and then we'll worry about when
we'll hit two I'd rather you open 20
great stores than 200 bad stores simply
to hit a goal and and this is so
meaningful because what our greatest we
know this our greatest constraint and
and truthfully more than most Industries
is access to Great technicians licensed
technicians you know bringing in
wonderful people and Brad's whole
mentality with that is
why am I going to work
people harder than they need to burn
them out to hit an arbitrary number at
the risk of potentially losing them long
term
and and of course this is inspired by
very much I mean he was an infinite
minded leader before your book but you
know through this this piece so remember
the goal of the infinite game is to stay
in the game right not to hit the goal
this year it's to stay in the game
longer than anybody else you Outlast
that's the point you build a strong
healthy business that can Outlast
fabulous and you know I really I think
that's something that I've watched in
hundreds and hundreds of businesses is
the constant desire to go try to find
new people hire new people grow and a
real lack of awareness and attention to
the relationship and the experience that
we're creating for our own people that
we already have with us
and and this is where your book is has
played such a major role because one of
the things that you talk about in there
is discretionary effort the concept of
people doing more than the bare minimum
and being engaged in a just cause so
what I find is people tend to nod their
head and go yeah just cause that's
exactly what we do but they they not by
the way that you've outlined it so would
you take a minute and just kind of
distinguish between a vision which I
think a lot of our companies have and
what a just causes and what the
distinction is here
the problem with the word vision is
there's no standard definition right
right and to some people a vision is
actually a just cause and they are
synonymous and to some people a vision
is a big long-term goal and to some
people uh a vision is something very
selfish you know most Visions are very
poorly articulated and they sound
something like this you know to be the
highest respected preeminent provider of
X with the greatest possible value you
know it's they're that's what they most
mostly sound like and that's all about
you Vision Just Cause And the reason I
called it a just cause is because it's
external it's a cause so just
that we would be willing to sacrifice in
order to advance towards that cause the
Declaration of Independence all men are
created equal that's a just cause will
we ever get there no we will not will we
die trying that's the point we will die
trying and so a vision is a world that
we imagine that's why we call it Vision
because we should be able to see it like
I have a dream that one day little black
children will hold hands on the
playground with little white children
it's a vision it's something that can be
seen in the imagination it is an ideal
state of the world that we're striving
towards and so a business
um a a good business generally does have
a just cause a vision of the future that
may not have anything to do with the
product or the service you know my
friend Bob Chapman he uh runs a company
called Barry waymiller it's a
manufacturing company they make large
machines for industry if you ask Bob uh
uh what's your vision for the company
he'll say to build great people to do
extraordinary things
and you'll say to Bob well how do you
measure success then he says we measure
success by how we touch the lives of our
people
in other words his vision happens to be
a vision for how to build the business
actually how to run the business to
build a business that is worth working
for it just so happens manufacturing is
the manner in which they pay for that
Vision yeah
um but it has nothing to do with the
product
it doesn't have to you know Steve Jobs
had a vision he had a just cause to
empower the individual to stand up to
Big Brother
it just so happened he lived through the
computer Revolution and the computer was
the perfect tool to help advance that
Vision but it has nothing to do with the
product is an idealized state of the
world that you want to live in and you
commit your energy and your and your
business to help build that cause
so you're you're starting to move us
down in a nice segue here on this but I
have specifically wanted to ask you that
I've given so much thought to what would
it just cause in the world of Plumbing
look like what would it just cause sound
like for an HVAC contractor or pest
control company so you've alluded to it
but can you take us a little bit further
and I I I'll just leave it at that and
then ask it well first of all it just
causes subjective and deeply personal it
can be whatever you want it to be right
some are big and lofty and some are not
so big and Lefty it's it's the thing
that that inspires you to get out of bed
in the morning and it doesn't even have
to be unique if you hear somebody else's
you're like I like that one then make
that one your own it's fine right
um you know we put a lot of pressure on
people that you have to come up with
your own Vision you don't you have to
find one that inspires you but you don't
have to you know whether it's the
Declaration of Independence or or civil
rights you know those weren't written we
didn't write those but we follow them
you know so um so something it could be
like uh some
um it could be something simple like uh
to live in a world in which every family
um uh feels safe and taken care of
we happen to do it through uh Plumbing
or HVAC you know and so when you say
safe and taken care of okay that's going
to determine the quality of work you do
that's going to determine what your uh
uh um invoicing process looks like and
what your your estimated process looks
like it's going to be how you explain
your product it's going to be the
customer service it's going to have an
impact that it's you're building a
business based on how people feel right
and you want them to be taken care of
not only by you but you're going to
install something in a way that they'll
never have to see you again you know
um
I was I visited um
India and uh one of the guys out there
he's living in a brand new condo you
know all new construction and he's got a
leak in his in his brand new condo and
so he had some guy come and fix it
and about two or three weeks later it
was leaking again
was leaking again and I said aren't you
a little bit annoyed that they're not
fixing it right the first time he's like
no no you don't understand there's so
many people in India they can never fix
it right the first time because then
you'll have too much unemployment
everything in India gets fixed not quite
right so that they can come back and
keep working
right there are people in this audience
who have employed that strategy a lot
yeah right and and we are lucky we we
have enough work to go around and I
think
one of the things that we forget is
especially in this industry right where
for the most part I think most people
view it as a commodity you know
um and the problem with commodities is
it's you know there's some that are
great there are some that are not so
great but but
I assume that most plumbers can fix my
toilet you know I I have that safe
assumption that most electricians can
like
do some basic stuff like installing new
you know new light bulb new lighting
fixtures
um and so beyond that that's why we
that's why we push on price because
you're not offering me anything else
right and so if you can think beyond
that in terms of the how how you um how
you're creative in the service that you
provide
um are you listening to your customers
uh when they're talking to you so let me
give you a silly example right let's say
um somebody comes in to uh
I don't know let's take a plumbing
example whether it's a new install you
know for a house that's being built and
you happen to meet the owners and they
talk about you know this is going to be
our baby's room and we're so excited
there's no Plumbing in the baby's room
they're just showing you the house and
then you're done with your job and when
you're done you leave a little baby gift
to say you know good luck with your new
home as opposed to saying I I fixed all
the plumbing right the ability to listen
to somebody that they feel seen and feel
heard I guarantee you everybody they
talk to won't talk about how great the
Taps work they're going to talk about
the little gift you gave to their kid
when you were done and they will
recommend you to absolutely everyone
and and that's it's the recommendation
we have a wallpaper guy that uh that
comes to our house I needed some
wallpaper done
he didn't do paste he was recommended to
me by a friend he came in to look he
says I can't do this job and he gave me
the name of somebody else right
the guy came he did a great job and I
said I told him who recommended him he
said oh I've never I met the guy once he
just heard I was good I guess the next
time I had anything done I immediately
called the original guy because he was
so honest
and so he's continued to do tons of work
for our whole family because he's so
honest so so this brings us to the point
of of the disconnect I think sometimes
in concept because I can promise you
this this audience here knows you know
what you just spoke to
these aren't your typical contracts yeah
these folks get that yeah they're doing
extraordinary things but there is still
a real challenge because as much as
leadership and owners get it there's a
disparity
in helping that just cause actually make
it to the front lines yeah and when
we're paying csrs at you know maybe
hourly rates customer service reps at
hourly rates we've got technicians that
are in the field who are you know maybe
not feeling particularly connected to
the company and I'm gonna add another
one the the wealth Gap in our own
industry is getting bigger than it's
ever been before yep owners and business
owners in our industry are seeing
success like like never before with the
influx of private Equity money and just
general you know businesses that are
part of service Titan
how do you get hourly employees people
who are maybe worried about you know
paying rent that are not high enough on
Maslow's hierarchy of needs yet to think
about fulfilling someone else's dreams
to be part of a just cause and want to
do more than just the bare minimum to
survive well this is the problem with
vision when you talk about you know when
you know the traditional Vision which is
to be the best you know or to hit some
certain Financial goal like literally
the front line person doesn't care about
that at all that literally is about you
not me yeah but when you when you um
when you say our our and I will go back
to the arbitrary example I gave you know
let's say to make everybody feel safe
and cared for right that's what we care
about and so we're going to actually
give you training
beyond the technical skills we're going
to give you training on how and human
skills right because we give hard skill
training we very rarely give human
skills training by the way I hate the
term soft skills hard and softer
opposite yeah good
um uh and so are we actually teaching
our Frontline folks how to how to um how
to have resolve conflict
I mean that happens
you know some somebody says I don't like
this work you've done how does that go
do you have any idea how that
conversation is going to go when you're
not there right you know are we teaching
them listening skills are we teaching
them how to give and receive feedback
maybe they have there's two or three of
them on a job and one of them is
slightly more senior like are we
teaching them these skills that make
them better at their job with each other
and with the with the customers and by
the way those are skills they're taking
home you're making them better human
beings
um and by making them better human
beings it makes them super loyal to the
company so I might get it offered a
better job somewhere else and you know
there's of course there are minimum
standards of pay that they have to meet
but at the end but there are once you
reach those thresholds somebody can say
I I'd rather work here because of the
way that my boss makes me feel because
the way the company makes me feel and I
think that there's a huge opportunity in
this industry in these industries to
double down on what quite frankly is
good leadership
um uh and I think one of the reasons
that the these industries are considered
Commodities is because we treat those
workers as Commodities we treat them as
is replaceable hourly workers and so
they act like Commodities and they treat
uh the customers like Commodities and
we've created that commodity industry
it's not necessarily the product itself
this is so good because you know I'm
thinking of the example you gave the
Barista at the Four Seasons in in the
book right and he's a barista at two
different places and one of them he
loves and one of them yeah and I think
about that because our technicians are
not leaving the the industry right
they're just going to another company
like they're not changing their careers
and and you talk about creating a place
in which people feel valued and here's
my observation I have met hundreds of
business owners who are absolutely
convinced that they've got a place where
people feel valued and thousands of
employees who don't feel the same way
about those businesses that's usually
right so what are what are some of the
how do we invite and and I'm going to
ask you to really lean in courageously
here to listen to this because you might
not enjoy the answer but what are some
signals for our business owners to
humbly confront that maybe they're not
creating the environment
that they think they are well first and
foremost
um uh have you ever gone to talk to
listen
you know the best the best businesses
leaders will on a semi-irregular basis
it could you know depending on the size
of the business it could be once a year
you know but but you go out to the field
or you call people up and say
how are you just checking in wanted to
see how you're doing
um or what do you tell me about I want
to learn about your career Ambitions
like you know how did you find yourself
in this profession like where do you
want to go like what are your Ambitions
how do you with kids do you have a
family tell me something about you do
you like working here you know can you
give me some what what is something that
we can do better what's something that
I'm not seeing like and and some of it
might be you know sort of helpful and
some of it might not be helpful but the
point is is you'll get information that
you ordinarily wouldn't get
um and most important they've probably
never been asked before ever and so
simply showing up
um to listen or take them out for lunch
and and and and and and get get their
input about the business
um what they they're on the front line
so they actually have a lot of customer
information that you don't have
um and so talking to them about what
they're hearing what they're seeing that
what other business opportunities do you
think they think there are
um listening is a big thing but then
that raises the question how many people
who are who are here who are going out
to the front line to listen know how to
listen
please go a little deeper here
because because the tendency what what
I've watched is this exercise executed
as you've described it
and then the first piece of feedback
that leader gets they said well that's
not true
and they start defending their position
correct so please a little insight on
what this means how to really listen so
when you listening is an active is is
active and listening is very difficult
you know you should be at the end of the
day of listening you should be exhausted
right because you're not listening for
words you're listening for meaning and
the goal of listening is not to prove
that you heard the goal of listening is
that they feel heard right
um and so you don't have to agree with
everything and you don't have to like
everything you have to take it in
you can ask clarifying questions but
remember they're going to take a risk to
tell you something and if you receive it
graciously they'll tell you more and
more and more and you'll develop a
relationship where honesty and truth
becomes the currency if you're defensive
or you attempt to correct or or dismiss
what they say they'll shut down and
they'll tell you what you want to hear
or tell you nothing because that's the
condition you created and so good
listening sounds like this can you tell
me um other things in this business that
you think that we can do better
and it doesn't matter if they're right
or wrong it's their experience and you
don't have to agree we always say that
if you have an emotional response if it
makes you angry or upset it's probably
true if you feel nothing about what they
said then maybe they misunderstood but
you can still take it all in write it
down and say tell me more
go on
go on what else and that's basically
your entire job what else go on and
you'll walk away the list and you'll be
like I knew these things are ready these
things I didn't know these things it's
just a bit of a Fest that's okay
everybody has that but you'll walk away
with some information but most
importantly they feel heard
so
I want to be really
um
authentic here in this I just came from
a keynote where I just shared
a very different message
specifically that that
listening to make people feel heard
runs the risk of not actually having
heard them that we can make people feel
heard without having done the listening
[Music]
and and I just I I want to share that
and just that now if we've heard them
they should feel heard
yes I think
I yes I think if you're if you're if
you're acting so that they'll feel heard
thank you uh uh it'll work once twice at
most because you're still being given
that information and they're gonna
there's an expectation that you're gonna
do something with that information even
if it's simply reporting out here's what
we heard these three things we can
address immediately these three things
are going to take us a little more time
um but we want you to know we heard you
and we're gonna we're gonna work on
these things I mean you might find out
there's some really like here's a great
one that I learned recently right
the um the average lifespan of a U.S
Postal Service Van
um was something like uh I think a year
or two years I can't remember it's it's
weirdly not very long where the average
lifespan of a UPS truck is something
like five years six years it's like 2x
right two or three x uh and the question
is well what are they doing differently
the maintenance is basically the same
you know it's it's similar similar Drive
trains it's all of that stuff
um uh USPS washes their trucks once a
week
and UPS washes their trucks every day
and how do you think somebody treats the
truck when they go to work that's their
office in a shiny new truck versus a
beat up old dirty truck right they they
will treat it differently and so
sometimes the things that make people
feel proud to go to work is like a clean
t-shirt a clean uniform nice tools you
know I mean some of this stuff is really
not very complicated to make people feel
really proud to go to work every day
yeah that's beautiful and that's that
was the broken windows theory in New
York where they started fixing windows
in high crime neighborhoods and crime
dropped right because they just felt
better about where they were it's a
beautiful sentiment so
um there's a there's a challenge here
that I want to check in with
and live TV
indeed and we've got a an audience right
now who is absolutely
enjoying extraordinary success
I mean they're going to see some numbers
tomorrow about like just what they're
doing but they know it as well I mean
they're growing they're profitable
they're in an expanding industry and
we've got private Equity money rolling
in at a rate that PE has said they
haven't seen anything like it in you
know 30 40 years and so forth
why would they change course to adopt a
Just Cause right now if winning and
playing a finite game is working at this
level I mean I'm not here to convince
anybody of anything you know uh the
question is what kind of business Do you
want to build like are you interested in
building a business that makes you as
rich as humanly possible
employees be damned and if if the
business fails when I leave or if the PE
puts so much pressure on me to make bad
decisions for the company that I know
it's going to destroy it so be it well I
mean that's your business I'm not going
to tell you you shouldn't do that right
I I'm I don't think there's a right way
to build a business the question is what
kind of business you want to build you
know do you want to build build a
business that serves as a legacy for you
you know
um do you want to do you want to lie on
your deathbed and say I wish I made a
little more money or do you want to lie
on your deathbed and say I I had an
impact in the lives of people that the
people who lived who who came through my
company you know uh made something of
themselves that they went on to build
great businesses
these are personal choices
um uh but at the end of the day I can
tell you that that that
that people who play with a finite
mindset
um
you know we we know you're playing with
the finance mindset it's very hard to
build uh trust with people around you
people relationships become very
transactional because when you treat
people transactionally they treat you
transactionally like I'm only gonna work
for you if you pay me the most money
but if somebody else pays me more I'm
out of here because those are the rules
you set
um uh you know it's it you also you you
tie your whole identity to that business
or to that to that Financial return so
that when and I see this with very
senior people or people who are near
retirement that when they get near the
end of their career they literally have
an identity crisis because their whole
identity is wrapped into a number or or
a business and so without the business
or without that number without that
growth they literally don't know who
they are and they go through serious
serious depression because they have no
other interest or identity outside of
that thing so these are just choices of
how people want to live their lives and
I'm not here to tell people how they
live their lives just rather that there
are different ways to look at it so
imagine at this point somebody is in
fact you know someone who has been
playing and they're recognizing through
this conversation that they've been
playing with a finite mindset and
they're inspired they're ready to go
back and start to change the game that
they're playing yep okay
almost every example in the book
is a new leader coming in and restoring
or engaging finite my in infinite
mindset I didn't necessarily hear a lot
of stories of leaders themselves
shifting from having played finite to
infinite right how do you do that how do
you go back to the same people you're
saying winning is everything true and
and humble yourself and bring them on
the journey with you to change course
so first of all let's be crystal clear
for the people who are freaking out at
this conversation
the infinite game
is not the absence of finite games right
it's the context within which finite
games exist nice and I'll give you a
real life example of someone who made a
conversion his name is Rick Elias he's a
very very important uh executive and
case study
um
uh Rick do you remember the US Airways
flight that landed on the Hudson a bunch
of years ago okay Rick was in seat 1A
and he tells the story of
the engines going out
and total silence
and preparing to die and what was going
through his mind was I'm either going to
die in a horrible fiery ball of you know
awfulness or I'm going to drown in the
icy Hudson that's pretty much what's
going to happen and you go through the
proverbial life flashing before your
eyes and all of that and the miracle was
that no one died and Rick talks about it
as the greatest lesson ever because
usually when people have a near-death
experience where they get to learn these
lessons usually they're survivor's guilt
because there is death and destruction
or there's there's pain and in this case
no one died no injuries it was the
perfect lesson
now Rick was a finite minded high-flying
driven executive prior who thought he
was hot because he built a company
worth 600 million dollars
um and he thought he was the bee's knees
right and you asked him if he thought if
he was good and it was good right and
he recognized that he'd sacrificed
relationships to make that money he
recognized that he'd sacrificed
happiness and health to make that money
and that near-death experience
transformed him to think of how he was
going to build his his business
completely differently
he's still a very A type personality
he's still very much driven to win you
know none of that went away but he
embraced an infinite mindset what he now
knows is an infinite mindset he and I
have gotten to know each other and
um here's what happens when you Embrace
an infinite mindset his business is now
worth 15 billion
and he will say a hundred percent that
his ability to grow from 600 million to
15 billion is because he changes mindset
if he kept that competitive mindset he
may have made an extra 100 or 200
million so we're talking huge numbers
right numbers that most people will not
conceive of in in a in in lifetimes
um and the irony is is businesses and
Executives and business owners that
Embrace an infinite mindset almost
always outperform their finite Brethren
Bob Chapman being one of them where I
talked about before an infinite minded
player who just destroys his competition
they say there are three ways to
transform your identity conditioning
change environment or significant
emotional event yeah right and the one
thing that they always say is we highly
recommend you don't wait for the
significant emotional event yeah don't
wait for them don't don't wait to
survive a plane crash exactly to learn
this lesson exactly and so conditioning
wise
and I have no doubt that you're there at
this point but please please go read the
infinite game it's an extraordinary work
a truly career-altering work
so I have two last questions for you uh
what would be the first step actionable
step someone could take towards finding
their just cause as they walk out of
here inspired
um
I mean literally imagine the world that
you want to live in like what is the
it's it sounds corny and cheesy but like
what's the world you want to live in and
that just cause will influence
your friends it'll influence who you
vote for it'll influence the way you
build your business and it'll you know
it'll Advance the influence the culture
of your company it'll influence the
products you invest in and how you
expand I mean
um uh it's it's it sounds kind of corny
I mean if you ask me my just cause I
imagine a world there are those words I
imagine right I imagine a world in which
the vast majority of people wake up
every single morning inspired feel safe
wherever they are and end the day
fulfilled by the work that they do
that's the world that I want to live in
and so I've committed all of my energy
in my career to help build that world I
personally have taken a bet on leaders
I've made it my choice to find support
and celebrate the leaders that I think
are more likely to build that world
because I know that I can't build it
alone it's going to take massive amounts
of companies and and and and Leadership
to create that world with me
um uh and so but I'm agnostic as to the
route that I take
um but that's the world I want to live
in so that's what I've committed to
knowing full well that I'll never get
there in my lifetime
and for me uh
you inspired me a just cause of ushering
in a world in which when people ask how
are you they really ask and when they
answer you really listen I mean that's
amazing right and and what I can tell
you is that over the last few days I've
had hundreds of people come up to me
telling me about the impact that your
work has had wow hundreds of people this
is a privilege and honor for us to be
here I mean this is just incredible and
I I
just hope uh that that we did the work
to
thanks honor your voice with this
audience I appreciate it yeah
you're very generous with your words
thank you but I want to underscore
listen to what his just cause was to
live in a world in which in which people
ask you how you are and mean it and and
then tell you what was it and then when
you answer they really listen and then
when you answer they really listen that
is absolutely applicable to absolutely
any business here and imagine how you
treat your people differently if that's
your vision imagine how you what
training you have to give to your people
that they would treat each other and
your customers so that you can build
that world the business is irrelevant
it's it's it's the manner in which you
conduct the business that matters
thank you this is a true honor and I can
promise I as a you know a follower I'm
only going to be a more
powerful advocate for you but the best
part is that you've got
I guarantee you 3 000 more right now oh
thank you very much uh this was an honor
to be here with appreciate it thank you
very much thank you
thank you
[Applause]